my name is Rodney Robinson I'm the 2019
National Teacher of the Year who are the
fire people was the most responsible I
teach at Virgin benefit education center
a school inside the Richmond juvenile
jail the Trailblazers I admire the most
is bred in Fred Hampton was the chairman
of the Black Panther Party in the state
of Illinois but he's got his start at 17
years old as a field secretary for the
n-double-a-cp he not only furthered the
black panther TenPoint party platform
but he began to unite all Americans
if one goal and that's for all power to
all people Fred Hampton was the same age
as my students when he when he began to
make a difference and so I often tell my
students you're never too young to have
a voice say what you want say what you
need the most powerful weapon you have
is your voice being Teacher of the Year
is really important because I represent
two groups who don't traditionally get
the mic and educational conversations
that first group is students in
alternative settings students that have
made mistakes but students who still
deserve a high quality education the
other group is black male educators we
only 2% of the educational force and
it's really important to get more of us
into the classroom to be proper role
models for all students and to show them
that they can be more they can be
anything they want to be so we're gonna
read the story when we saw when students
come to me I'll tell them that this is
your second chance and the education is
the best way to take advantage of your
second chance and my goal is to create a
positive experience in a positive
environment because I can change the
trajectory of their life you see change
that needs to be made in your community
you are the change use your voice speak
up advocate go to your city councilman
go to your school board go to the ever
but you have the power all power to the
people